good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
happy Thursday I am so excited to be
joined in studio with a kind of fresh
face you know a young a genzer how old
are you 20 redacted 20 27 oh okay you're
kind of like a jenzy yeah we're like
kind of young us like kids yeah it's
Connor wood also known as fibula but I
like to call him the fibs does anybody
call you that yeah everybody everybody
does so much so that they don't know
that I have a name honestly I did I knew
your name was Connor I had no idea what
your last name was yeah it's tough
because people are like who who's coming
Connor I didn't know your name was Conor
it's kind of how I feel like girl no job
Claudia like J turd Trudy it's hard well
thank you for being here thanks for
having me I'm so excited I'm also I'm
also scared you should be this is like a
lot of expectation I fully expect you I
want you to be hilarious smart funny
Intrepid rattle it off yeah everybody
does I had people texting me from past
lives like I like I had won the lottery
cuz they heard about this and they're
reaching out hey I know we haven't
talked but I just wanted I I felt like
Justin Bieber when his dad reached back
out when he when he hit F love it was
it's been it's been a journey I had
people coaching me this morning my
cousin texted me like are you fresh like
you should be up it was 6:00 a.m. I'm
like I don't you know it's just a short
short drive did you um read up on the
stories are you tell me like your your
um interest in pop culture levels I'm
interested in pop culture and at at any
level at any level I love that I did get
I don't know if this is behind the stuff
but I did get to check out the stories
yes I wanted to give you like a fair a
fighting shot in now yeah I was scared I
was like I need to I need to be a little
prepped cuz you can get torn up if
you're not prepped you can get torn up
if you're not prepped and you can also
get torn up if you have like a bad Take
On Pop Culture you know happens to us
all the time yeah no I'm just kidding
we're going to have a great time and I
have to say I was really shocked so many
people were not shocked but you know no
no no keep going delighted that so many
people were so excited you have your own
podcast BR and Conor make a podcast that
people love and they're so excited for
the crossover but you know we have a
very wide vast audience and not everyone
might be familiar with your work and I
feel like even I like where did you come
from like how did you get started I know
you from Tik Tok I know you from
Instagram I think we met through Erin
and Carly we've only met like twice tell
me who is fibs who is fibs and where
does fibula come from it's the name of a
bone correct it's it is yeah it's a bone
in your leg I just learned that you
actually don't even need it wow which
was like an interesting it's kind of
very you it was kind of very like a
therapy topic almost like oh you you
don't need the bone and I was like
there's no way you don't need a full
bone in your leg you don't you but like
where in the leg sh it's behind your
this one in your shin when I think of
fibula I of course think of the bone
song from Hannah Montana do you mind um
walking me through the bone song then
comes the tibia that ain't no fibula
tching up the holes and then and now I'm
up to my knee yeah yeah yeah that's the
patella to me we're doing The Bone Dance
did you watch Hanam Manana growing up I
did yeah I had a little sister sister
too I would have watched it anyways but
I had a little sister so I yeah I've got
all the everything down um so everyone
started calling fabula fabula when
during college yeah I changed it during
college cuz you know what funny so
during college I used to go to this
music festival and I wanted Instagram
followers I was like I was Cloud hungry
from birth I so appreciate your honesty
I am Claudia ashy the crazy beautiful
life of an Instagram thirst monster I'm
all about embracing The Thirst yeah you
have to I mean it's it's who we are it's
the way
um so I wanted an easy Instagram name
that I could say one word you know at
music festivals um and my my friends I
had the justtin Bieber haircut and they
would all run up to me and be like can
we get a picture can we get a picture so
that we could pretend that I was on
Wizards Waverly Place on Disney Channel
and we would go to the front of the
Justin Bieber was not on Wizards of
Waverly Place yeah I I later on I was
like oh how did that work ever you know
when I was younger a lot of people
actually thought I was snooky and I used
to get approached on the street for
pictures all that
it was the same thing yeah it was like
you can kind of convince people of
anything if you run up to someone for a
picture that's like kind of one of the
lessons of like adulthood you realize
like people are so dumb they're so dumb
and if you're smart you're just kind of
winning you are but I kind of wish I was
a little bit more dumb it seems so nice
and relaxing Blissful ignorance is a
real thing it's so true I feel like you
were smart in high school and college
you were right to college I went to UT
Austin Texas yeah it was amazing hook
him hook him y you were so close I'll
take that hook him the coyotes I knew it
you give like Smart Energy like not nerd
but like annoying smart well oh you
forgot to moistu on my face yeah oh
don't worry our cameras aren't that high
high quality nobody zoom in no one's
going to say um I also texted right
before as I was walking upstairs you
guys have a steamer cuz I looked down I
was like I didn't a little disheveled
are you hung over no it's that the best
it's it's better than drinking which is
so oh my God it's better than drinking
you wake up you wake up and you look at
people that out and you go you guys are
losers no like get your life together
freaks the way I'm like so like when I'm
not hung over I'm like my God you're
literally a slob and then when it's me I
can't fathom God complex okay I feel
like we've gone on a tangents so you're
you were called fabula in high school
college I'm so jealous by the way that
you had a nickname in college All I Ever
Wanted growing up was like a cool
nickname I tried to get people to call
me like juice box it didn't take and
that's why I'm so like leaning Into My
turdy Lou nickname which was like just
born how nicknames are born naturally
yeah why juice boox well I I missed that
I don't know if that's common know no it
I wanted a nickname and I thought juice
boox was cool so I was like here from
here to four please refer to your girl
as Juicebox and not one person did
doesn't work like that you can't you
can't make your own nickname you can't
manufacture a nickname like guys chains
right you can't buy those they have to
come to you they have to be gifted in a
gift or you find it on the street right
right right right right and a a gift
from God so when did you start content
creating um on accident during coid oh
oh I got laid off of I've been laid off
of every job I've ever you know laid off
or or forcefully because everyone was
like so threatened to by your talent it
must have been that I guess um no it
wasn't that it was cuz I was bad at my
jobs what was the job um I worked at
Bumble for a while right outside of
college yeah that was awesome um and
then after that I went to bird the
scooter company on the marketing team I
love bird I wish I had it in the city
like when I'm in like Europe I'm you're
going to catch me zoom in you know me
people would be dead this morning on
birds I know it is so fun that you
forget that you're moving at like 30 m
hour and I actually I was hit by a
vehicle in Portugal while on a a bird
and thankfully I'm
okay but I do understand the risk I got
hit by a bird so hard somebody on the
bird hit you no you were on the bird no
I was on the bird I got hit by a a
Toyota Corolla yeah oh my God which is
like no that's like the car you want to
get hit by no cuz like if I'm thinking
insurance I want to get hit by a Bentley
I wasn't cuz it was my fault oh you're
right you're right okay then it's
definitely c um well I want to get hit
by a G wagon and I'll just smush against
the oh beny would be better yeah or
honestly like I feel like really wealthy
people actually travel around in like
big Cadillac Escalades a Lincoln
Navigator a Chevrolet Suburban something
more subtle yeah yeah yeah um quiet
luxury quiet luxury okay we're going on
a thousand bird sorry so you got laid
off I got well hey I want to say really
quick on the on the on the bird thing I
have to show you my bruise when we get
offline I don't know if you want to put
this in the visual oh no from getting
hit by the car I got hit by this car I
was in the air for so long that I
actually had time to be like Oh I'm
still in the air wow this is incredible
I brought it up during my interview at
bird once they didn't like respond right
away and so I was like oh they probably
didn't hear it second time then I
figured out like they don't want to hear
that of course not they probably thought
you were like a mole about to serve them
with papers and I was like leveraging my
lawsuit against them so they would like
hire me a threat yeah no I'm just was
thought it was funny just sharing
thought it was funny classic like people
are like I'm so sorry that happened
you're like no no it was funny classic
fibs classic fibs so yeah people start
started call oh no fibs because of uh
the Instagram and then during Co started
posting on Tik Tok and I didn't have
that like I wasn't like the Emily Maro
I'm not the mayonnaise guy you know like
you don't have a thing it was just like
very slow growth and they kind of got
bigger and bigger and then I started
talking to the camera and then I was
like oh I can like do this full time so
how long were you content creating
before you like fully quit your job and
did I was fired I was totally unemployed
I was actually I applied to 57 jobs wow
weirdly couldn't get one shocking I
thought it was smart weirdly because of
that gnarly digital footprint that was
like that was sweeping the
globe um I couldn't uh get any responses
so I was like okay this is this is fine
um then I finally was like I guess I can
lean into this until it goes away right
and it hasn't yet do you you have any
wood in the studio yeah I love to knock
on wood yeah oh nice that's fabulous and
so now you're full-time content creating
you have your own podcast podcast yeah
are you here for Fashion Week on
accident tell oh so you you're not you
didn't fly in for Fashion Week events
you just were what are you in town for
um I came in we went to The Hamptons
last weekend oh fun I sent you a picture
I I I met I ran into joey yes he's the
best he is the best he's really
one-of-a-kind character he is and it was
like there was no learning curve with
him it was like I walked him he's like
hey I love you I was like I don't know
do you think I'm someone else but he's
exactly the same person in real life
that he is on social media in his
podcast which is so refreshing it's it
was awesome like I had such a great time
I ended up like I was like oh all my
friends left I'll just hang with Joey
yeah well I was I was talking to him for
so long I just like got distracted um
the best it was it was awesome but the
Hamptons were great um I I left I have
this goal I have a birthday coming up
and I have this goal I wrote down a list
of aend able goals this year okay I love
that um I hope being the toast was one
of them the I mean this was this would
have been not an unattainable goal to
I'm being serious you're fibbing I'm no
I'm being dead ass and um so I made
attainable goals this year one is to
watch The Sopranos oh you know that's a
good one I haven't watched it I haven't
either and I feel like I'm missing out
on a lot of conversation but let me tell
you how Tik Tok ruins everything because
I've literally seen the very last scene
of The Sopranos which is apparently like
this huge like it's like a Scorsese
moment you're supposed to like extra
what it means I literally like saw it
and watched somebody like give their
whole take on it it's like I know what
happens why' you you should cuz I was
I'm never going to watch The Sopranos it
sucks because every time we give a
spoiler alert on like a show that came
out like 15 17 years ago we get a text
to say I was going to watch that tonight
no you weren't that happens all the time
like I'm watching Suits right now which
is from 2016 every single person I I
need to watch suits too you by the way
you do it's literally the attainable
goal attainable goal um and what is like
the social etiquette rule rules on
speaking about a show that's 10 years
old uh you had your chance you had your
chance like okay when we recap like The
Bachelor or things that are currently on
love Island like okay I understand I'm
not going to give a spoiler and I'll be
I'll do a big spoiler alert I'll say
skip the next couple of minutes of the
podcast but if I'm literally rewatching
something like what was I watching
people were like I can't believe like
young
Sheldon no you're kidding me the show
Premier six years there's a statute to
limitations where you can talk about a
show also if you can skip like you have
the option to not watch the end of The
Sopranos right same thing here so true
it's tough so your goals you were saying
my goals so one of them you know is
watch that Sopranos and then one of them
is to start putting away my clothes if
I'm in a location for more than one day
hang them up suitcase put them in the
dresser so when you change and stuff
you're not you don't end up having a
inevitable pile of clothes on your
suitcase I did it this weekend in the
Hampton I did it I did it and I was like
I just it changed it was like not
drinking waking up not hung over I was
like oh I'm God you didn't know how you
ever traveled not like this no I was
like I live in this home momentarily at
least in this time um and then I left
the Hampton I was like unpacked and my
suitcase is fresh is fresh because I
didn't unpack the whole dresser I was
like I forgot to so I left half of my
clothes that were in the dresser oh no
so sometimes your goals can bite you
back back in the ass bite bite your ass
I was actually going to ask if you left
anything that's true something sometimes
like spreading all your clothes out in a
facility whether it's a hotel or an air
BB it's nice but it's not feasible for
packing that [__] back up it's not and I
was thinking I would gas at myself I'm
like maybe I just packed better on the
way out which is never the case no of
course not so you so much extra space
it's so much yeah I was like oh this is
zipping usually I have to kind of
wrestle my suitcase like a Steve Irwin
style Gator wrestle this Gator down rest
in peace may he rest may he rest anyways
I feel like we did it again we did it
again we're kind of like tangent girlies
me and you oh my God I I do this so you
were content creating I do this on every
podcast it's good it's good it's fun
it's fresh it's a way to keep the
conversation flowing facts so you're in
New York that's what you were saying met
Hampton you met Joey I'm getting it and
you just happened to be here during
Fashion Week will you be attending any
Fashion Week events yes so exciting I
came and I was like I'm here for the
week I have no plans I'm going to make
some damn Tik toks of course I'm going
to I'm going to do this all of a sudden
every single moment of every day has
filled up I'm late to everything okay
that's like annoying I don't have any
clothes cuz they're in the Hamptons I'm
having to run to Soho every 10 minutes
you got to go to a zar men's has good
stuff I'm sprinting back and forth to
Unico Unico you're so Unico it's a good
store and there's no label there's no
brand on anything I know I like that but
you know I've actually I've never
purchased anything in unil clo except
maybe one time I bought like some ski
pants or something it has they have
everything they it's huge and would you
say Unico is your favorite store I'm
having a I'm having a bit of a Unico
moment in time yeah love that it's nice
I like it it's like thermals right quiet
luxury quiet luxury really cheap I love
that for you yeah it's great well you
look great thank you very podcast
appropriate attire thank you it's all I
had left so I just worked out and would
you say that the wrinkles on your shirt
are from the poor packing or the
unpacking in the hotel room uh the
wrinkles are are just like a
conglomerate of everything that's
happened to me I don't know how people
don't have Wrinkle in their clothes
honestly I know like I'm going to show
up wrinkly and I I still I have like a
handheld steamer at home that I love and
I steam everything like when I go to an
event and between getting out in and out
of the Uber just like being me I will
show up wrinkly like how do people not
turd wrinkl the third turd wrinkl the
third thank you for kind of elaborating
on my nickname you don't know how much
it means to me and like my inner child
course of course I'm so happy to do it I
I meant to say my my nickname in college
was not fibs that was more my name my
nickname was cter for some reason ter
which was tough that was a tough build
to swallow but it comes God gives you
your nickname I had nicknames come from
some embarrassing like bad story like
skid marks you know something like that
speaking of skid marks speaking of skid
marks we actually do have a story today
about skid marks that I will do my best
to like not vomit through I didn't talk
about it yesterday cuz like I honestly
didn't want to talk about it but today
there was like limited stories and we
are going to be talking about the Delta
Duty gate okay and we are going to be
talking about on another note the US
Open you and I both went last night you
have a good time should we talk about it
when we get there we should because the
weather is a factor that tangent could
go that tangent could go well let me ask
you a question you're here during the
most demonic satanic Heatwave and people
on my Instagram I was posting today
they're like it is technically like 87°
which yes I know in Phoenix it's 105 and
they're like well if you can't handle
that don't move to Phoenix I wasn't I
wasn't going to move to Phoenix but tell
me it it doesn't feel like 110 degrees
like there's no way it's 85 why are we
constantly in a battle about who's
experiencing the worst things true it's
not a competition it's not it sucks here
so bad soad I am sweating right now and
by the way the air conditioning is on in
here closed the blinds today because
once the sun pours in like we're done I
was staying at the Marlton hotel and iay
to say that no I'm trying to get them to
pay me to say that you're doing a good
job I saw I saw your Tik talk about the
water pressure it's it's going bonkers
kind of water pressure is like a really
big deal in hotels in life but
especially in hotels well I
think what we can cut this I think the
shower is broken but but I like we're
cutting it we're not no I'm kidding they
reposted on their story so you think
it's not meant to be that no and I'll
tell you why because I had a room the
night before where I was out all day I
said I need to get in this AC in these
crisp Hotel sheets nothing better and I
I get up there and it's I go it's the
same temperatures outside in here I I
call I'm like please this can't be this
can't be my life this can't be my
reality and they're like we'll come up
and check they come up and check no it's
just hot it's hot outside and that's how
hot it is in this room I go I can't do
it I can't you got to help me please you
have to help me they moved me to a
different room and the shower nice and
the shower was different yeah I I
preferred it it was nice it would have
killed like an old person yeah well I'm
a young person and it's about 10 yeah
hit me hard so biibs are you ready for
like your big first moment on the toast
with the fast five stories woo I'm so
ready I'm excited right here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by State Farm the State Farm
personal price plan helps you create a
plan that gives you options so you get
an affordable price and it comes with
the lot of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlists podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common spoiler
alert they're a reflection of you and we
all know that my social media is full of
right now lots of tennis cuz I'm kind of
in like my tennis girl era and I've also
ended up on like mararo Tik Tok which is
just exciting and you know interesting
and it's a reflection of me so that's
what the State Farm personal price plan
has in common too it gives you almost it
gives you options that you can
personalize your coverage with so you
can protect yourself and what you care
about most at an affordable price just
for you so you can see more of yourself
reflected in everything that you love
which is kind of a dream you know just
between you and I so like a good
neighbor State Farm is there what I love
about the State Farm personal price plan
is like it really is so customizable and
personal to you like Jackie and I I feel
like we're two of the most similar
people in the world but even our
insurance needs are so different Jackie
lives in another state she owns a home
she has her Tesla me I'm a renter we all
have different things you know so call
her go to statefarm.com today to create
your State Farm personal price plan
again prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability
availability and El eligibility may vary
again options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
today's episode is also brought to you
by neutral so did you know that hair
thinning will happen to approximately
one in two women your girl being one of
them if you're among them them know that
you're not alone thinning is normal and
neutral helps women address it from
within with science-backed supplements
so there's a ton of different reasons
why someone could experience hair
thinning for me it was like a total
shift in diet and weight loss that can
be a common trigger and I felt like so
panicked when I first noticed it
especially up here by my hairline it was
just so much more visible scalp and
that's not something I'm really
interested in and when it came time to
find something to do about it everyone
in my life recommended neutri fall and
I've had really great success with it I
have visibly thicker hair now so neutri
fall is the number number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement it's clinically shown to
improve visible thickness and strength
from postpartum to menopause to
plant-based Lifestyles and no matter
your life stage nutrifol has four unique
formulas to support women each is
physician formulated using drug-free
science backed ingredients so you get
the most reliable results they support
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting the root causes of thinning
which can be stress hormones environment
nutrition lifestyle and metab metabolism
and they do that through whole body
health so in a clinical study 86% of
women reported improved hair growth
after taking neutral women's hair growth
supplement for 6 months take the first
step to visibly thicker healthier hair
for limited time neutral is offering our
listeners $10 off their first month
subscription and free shipping when you
go to neutr fall.com and enter promo
code the toast so find out why over
4,000 Healthcare professionals recommend
neutral for healthier hair neutral is
spelled n u r a fool.com promo code the
toast that's neutri fall.com promo code
the toast and today's first story is of
course another development in this
jojonas
drama now two things came out yesterday
that I found very interesting the first
was this news that Jo Jonas allegedly
caught Sophie Turner in a compromising
ring camera footage before filing for
divorce so they're citing this as like
the last straw for Joe they didn't say
what it was it would could be that she
said something that she did something
she was with someone we are now left to
the imagination of course everyone's
thinking you know who is she coming home
with like they really left a lot to the
imagination and I'm curious what would
it take first of all what do you think
was on the ring camera footage nothing
really yeah who's calling it
compromising who's who's it who's it
will to call it compromise is did they
pick that word like the people who had
well page six did pick that word but you
know TMZ everyone is using their own
sort of vernacular I don't know it
sounds like a smear campaign to me so
what's so funny is that like this entire
narrative is clearly coming from Joe's
Camp it's been like she's been out
partying he's with the kids it's all
making him look so complimentary and I
think it's actually having the adverse
effect on people nobody's being like Oh
Joe what a doting Dad it's like this is
a little too convenient it's a little
too good and then the second update that
I was going to share which I found very
odd was that he was Paparazzi yesterday
sitting outside at a restaurant with the
two daughters taking them to lunch the
daughter's faces were blurred which
makes me think like the paparazzi um
setup like was set up by his camp like
it's not the law the law in this country
to blur out in Europe it is and a lot of
the times actually not even sometimes
people respect it it's not the law so
the faces were blurred out we have I've
never seen a Paparazzi picture of their
kids before like this was the first time
it was just like a little too convenient
for me yeah and now I think I'm having
the reaction that everyone's having it's
like well everything so far has that's
been come out is like extremely
complimentary to Joe it's a little too
convenient all of this I agree I agree
and it's it's coming out like all at
once too and it's funny cuz the at face
value the the the headlines are like
very projo anti- Sophie mhm Sophie's
very quiet and all this which usually
you know The Quiet One is usually I have
nothing to hide like come at and and you
see the smear campaign come out from the
other side it sucks as Jo so nice I know
the thing is they're both fabulous
people and this is hard for the Joon and
so stands because you don't know whose
side to take but if I had to take a side
just based on the information I've been
given I'm going to be leaning Sophie oh
fully because she's given us nothing and
like I always feel it's tough when two
people get divorced and they have kids
it's very limited in what you're going
to say about the father or the mother of
your children but it seems like they're
not you know holding back on team Joe no
and it's it's crazy cu the headlines are
brutally brutally also Pro Joe but
online everyone's like seeing right
through it I know he's somewhere
throwing up right now I'm actually
shocked at like the media literacy of
people on the internet because some
people on the internet can be so dense
and like the internet leaves no room for
like nuanced conversation so for people
to be seeing through this and being like
what's really going on here I find it
it's crazy it's crazy I bet something's
coming out as we speak um I know it is
it is sad and it's also when I was
searching for stories today every single
headline was a new update and like
development there's nothing else going
on in the world besides these two
because it's so first of all shocking
like I don't think anybody thought these
two were headed for divorce anytime soon
but the amount of stuff coming out is
just like bizarre for two really private
people yeah it's also it's weird coming
off of this like
insane comeback of the Jonas Brothers as
a whole it's like that's all been like
we are every everything everywhere all
at once this whole thing it's all super
positive we're meeting everybody family
back together no one has a negative
thing to say and then that's is like
coming off the heels of that true it's
almost like you rise too fast and then
something has to happen no you know what
John even though they're already so
famous likeability is a prison it was
chilling when he said that and he was
right cuz like he like you know got
canceled basically just for getting
divorced which is not a crime but like
in this case it was yeah likeability is
a prison you're right the Jonas Brothers
aside from their you know break up have
been kind of gotten off scotf free when
it comes to Scandal and PR they're
having a moment I'm kind of loving this
bad boy era I'm not going to lie yeah
it's it's interesting I I think that
we're going to like see the end of it or
or like get whatever information it this
feels like when the the government was
like we have the UFO footage and we're
like show it to us then nah show us a
footage yeah if it's if you have it also
I think it's just a great
um strategy for hyping up their tour
because now every time they they're
still currently on tour they went on
stage last night now every time they go
on stage moments are being filmed and
made into Tik toks that are going viral
you know last night they started off the
show with a group hug and it made news
like who cares um so it is in a way a
strategy I guess all press is good press
it sucks that it's on Sophie's back I
sometimes I'm like I I feel icky that
we're like this is like a family's you
know divorce that's how I felt about um
and I didn't even choose it as a story
today with Courtney Kardashian and
Travis Barker he canceled all those
shows in Europe and flew home because
she was having pregnancy complications
she posted on Instagram yesterday just
kind of clarifying what it was she had
fetal surgery which is really serious
but I think people were like dying to
know what was going on with Corney it's
like can this pregnant woman have some
privacy I know that's like such the nuan
thing it's like you you chose this life
this thing you this is part of your job
I know I don't subscribe to that like
notion that celebrities who chose this
life especially a celebrity like the
Kardashians who really did it's not like
they were discovered as an actress like
they chose this life um I don't
subscribe to that like social construct
where they're ENT like we entitled to
every piece of information that's going
on in their lives like I just don't
subscribe to that yeah I don't like that
at all it's gross yeah even when I see
someone in public doing something which
this is already out so I'm just going to
say it say it but I like walked I was
walking through Washington Square Park
the other day trying to get yeah trying
to get Davis burlson to probably jump my
jump my bones I was like I I want to get
on what's popping but I want to like run
into him you know I you want it to be
staged you just have to hang out sleep
in the park I can't I know it's too damn
to hot no in the park is packed oh yeah
so it's too damn hot for me to be
briefly outside it's not too damn hot
for mely to be wearing black huge cargo
pants and combat boots and making out
making just when I saw him he was just
dangling on this girl I don't know how
people are being physical with their
loved ones in this weather at the US
Open yesterday Ben's like shoulder was
touching me and his legs he was like
manspreading I was like if you don't get
your hot body off of me because Ben is
just a furnace at all times and during
the winter I love it like I'm never cold
my feet like are always like touching
his shins he's so warm I said if you
don't get the [__] away from me like
we're going to have a problem the seats
are this big the seats are tiny Ben is a
broad guy yeah I was not having it it
was actually demonic outside last night
I don't know how people are just making
out in the park I also don't know how
people make out in the sub maybe they're
from Arizona maybe they're maybe this is
a walk in the park literally for them
maybe I can't do I also I don't know how
people like swap spit on the subway I
think that's really disgusting whenever
I see like that couple making out on the
subway I'm like have you ever heard of
germs yeah just germs in the air wait so
if you're you're from New York you can
touch you just touch everything here you
just carry like gerx yes I'm not one of
those people who like has um you know
that uh device they like sell it all
over Tik Tok eligible for commission you
like put it around your finger and it's
like a stick and you can like push your
elevator buttons with it and you open
doors with you get gas with it you don't
get g i touch stuff like I have to live
and I get home and I wash my hands and I
never get in my bed within my outside
clothes facts I bite my nails which
sucks that's tough in New York oh yeah I
have to stop you you do this is like a
good lesson in that cuz I'm also very
aware of when I touch stuff I can't get
in bed with outside hands no definitely
not I'll get in bed and be like when's
the last time I wash my hands have to
get out yeah but is that like a thing
you've always done cuz for me when we
all became super conscious of washing
our hands during Co I of course started
following the rules yeah and that really
stuck for me cuz I used to like get home
during coid and wash my hands and
everything and then get in bed and I was
thinking before coid like I didn't used
to do that yeah that was a nice little
refresher for a lot of people I think we
were all like singing Happy Birthday
while washing our hands twice yeah I was
actually singing toast by Claudia ashre
because it's the same length should
should do you want to refresh every I I
mean no I don't need to I feel like
everybody knows it was the song of the
summer the summer of course um and then
of course my follow-up hit 100% 100% in
2021 I just feel like the music kind of
speaks for itself yeah 100% do you sing
No I feel like you're just one of those
people who's multi-talented no I'm not
what are your talents like what's your
party trick for me it's like karaoke um
you do Impressions like what do you do I
don't do I don't have any party tricks I
don't think really I think you're always
partying I am out and about I get really
bad fomo which like I need to I think
that I need that needs to be on my
attainable goals list is to like fix
that by the way that's so real which I
think that's just therapy would do that
to do the trick I I I do think also it's
just growing up like we're in that stage
now we're like approaching 30s me a
little bit more than you um and I do
think that's definitely like something
you phase out of in your 20s where like
you don't care to miss I'm actually
stoked to be in my bed yeah yeah right
it's the best I'm doing it this week cuz
I don't know how people are doing it I
know they go they're at things all day
events and they liter change in the car
they're changing their clothes that's
enough to do me in I completely agree
changing in a car trying things on also
I have ptsc being an Old Navy with my
mom she's like lift up your shirt and
turn around I'm like
I literally I [__] can't like I'm
going to pass out here and I'm going to
throw a fit like I agree trying on
clothes is a seven circle of hell I got
one pair of pants in me to try on and
then I have to if they don't fit I'm I'm
out no I actually will not try things on
anymore like if I go to a store that's
reasonably priced like I'm not talking
about expensive clothes I'm talking
about like everyday clothing whether
it's you know like aara I don't try on I
buy things that like most likely will
fit if they do great if they don't I'll
still make it work like it's just it's
not my problem literally the skirt that
I'm wearing I bought from Zara I did not
try it on it is big on me and I've worn
it twice like that's like I don't care
um there's a hack I saw it on Tik Tok
for trying pants on I just remembered I
don't know if it works for skirts you
grab the two farthest waist ringlets
yeah and you you bring it around your
neck and if they if they kiss they are
the right size and it worked 100% of the
time everyone was stitching it and it
was working for everybody okay I guess I
I love a good Tik Tok hack but explain
the science to me I don't I don't I'm
not I've never claimed it I can't have
to do with your hips and what if you're
you know an apple figured girl I think
like girth pair figure not here is is
somehow equivalent or relative yeah I
guess I don't know about I'm going to
try that I think we should all try it I
I saw it like 15 I confirmed it before
cuz we talked about on our podcast to I
was like I don't want to spew
misinformation as much as I have not
tried it no I guess that would be that
would be the kicker yeah is it for men
and women that's a great I I love so you
spoke about your podcast but you but you
literally did no research no that's our
that's kind of our that's kind of our
whole thing is like speaking on things
we know that's that's our biggest
comments review when people leave
podcast reviews they're like do your
research no what do you think this is
the encyclopedia podcast they make up
facts I'm like we got to move on if we
say something and we just go with it we
don't have time to Google that's so me I
mean it's it's the way to go and people
get bored when you get when you have a
hangup this is not a thesis no and
people also get bored cuz we used to get
a lot of flack they're like do your
research do you know anything so then
we'd be actively like researching things
on the podcast Jackie has her iPad I
have my iPad so we'd be like how old is
shif for L nobody wants to hear someone
typing and like oh wait this website
says she's 37 but this one says she's 35
like that's boring do you panic when
you're like actually in the typing I
type everything wrong we have we luckily
have like a TV then we have a one of our
producers like types it in for us listen
sound off in the comments would you
prefer your podcasters know nothing or
spend like minutes researching yeah it's
kind of fun to know nothing it you know
what it's like life is a mystery we
talked about this already too being dumb
is nice being dumb is nice it's relaxing
all right are you ready for our next
story that was a nice tangent from the
Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner news um
Taylor momson of of uh Gossip Girl fade
says she was made fun of relentlessly as
a kid for her alienating role in The
Grinch movie now of course when we think
Taylor momson we think Jenny Humphrey
but real ones will know where are you
Christmas why can't I find you you have
a nice voice I can hit really low and
really quiet oh more of a Harmony yeah I
don't have you have like a phenomenal I
like American Idol Discovery voice so
when I was in college um I every
semester took a two extra an extra class
that was two credits so by the time I
graduated I only had to take a few
classes and every semester it was a
singing class it was only two credits it
was like an hour a week and it was the
time of my life and I went into my first
one and I was like I'm going to try out
for xfactor by the end of this year so
like let get me attainable goal
attainable goal let's get me riled up
and unfortunately the teach the teachers
were all like music grad students who
like this was the B of their existence
and they couldn't have cared less and
there was just a curriculum that they
had to follow and it was like classical
music it was classical singing and I had
to learn all these like dumb hymns HS
hnis hims and I was willfully unprepared
by the end of the semester um I really
was planning on trying out for xfactor
and she was like all right let me know
how it goes our last class is next week
and it was supposed to be that week and
I was dating my husband at the time and
he had a car I was like going to drive
me and we're going to go and when the
day came he like couldn't drive me he
like was busy or whatever and I was
honestly like not even in the mood to
try out and so like the next week with
for the final class I had to like lie
and be like it went really well we'll
see how it goes I'm not sure it was just
like round one then I never saw her
again wow that could have been like your
life could have taken off in a
completely different direction we'll
never know I know I'm glad it didn't
kind of well a goal is to be on the mask
singer I did uh one time I was reach out
they asked me to put in an audition tape
but I guess it wasn't good enough cuz I
never got cast did you do you sang for
them duh I forget what I sang but I was
amazing you singing the National Anthem
I can't believe you're not going to do
that um I know I know and like honestly
I I know I'm a good singer like not to
be annoying like I know I have talent I
could do comedy in front of thousands
and not feel even remotely nervous I do
not think I could sing in front of
people like I really it's honestly very
personal to me like I love singing I've
been singing since I was a kid like if
anybody were to say that was bad I
couldn't take it like you don't like by
comedy sure that's fine comedy is very
personal you know you don't think I'm
funny whatever if you don't like by
singing like I'll cry I could have
someone tell me like they hate me to
death and that they want to kill my
family but if they tell me one of my
videos is not funny it Mak it ruins my
whole week really but see comedy is so
personal personal like depending on the
person's you know trauma depending on
the person's I've experience so if
somebody doesn't like my comedy yet
hurts cuz I work really hard at it 100%
but
I can understand cuz there are people
who I literally don't think are funny
who are so famous like I literally I'm
not going to say who I just saw someone
open for Dave Chappelle and it was
literally the least funny thing ever I'm
like literally how are you here and
people were like dying I'm like this is
literally not funny comedy is personal I
know so I I really don't take it I don't
take it personally but my singing like I
I could I couldn't survive that there
have been lesser that have come before
you in saying the national anthem it's
true Fergie yeah it's true yeah true
yeah that is all-time favorite video but
back to this Taylor momson story so she
went on everyone's talking about it the
uh podcast podc Crush which is hosted by
pen Badgley who played her older brother
in Gossip Girl so it's all very Synergy
um and they spoke a little bit about
gosip girl but they actually spoke more
about the Grinch and how it like really
kind of ruined her life so she said
first of all the Grinch changed my life
in a multitude of ways one of them being
that I was made fun of
relentlessly she explained that making
friends was always challenging every
time I would start a new school or go
somewhere else I don't even think think
the kids knew my name I was just Grinch
girl not even the character's name just
Grinch girl I got used to it but it was
alienating this is devastating to hear I
think the Grinch is the best Christmas
movie of all time and she's so precious
in the film with her little nose and her
braids yeah this is devastating to know
she probably like regrets doing it it's
so sad as a you're a child a child being
a child actor I'm always you know Josh
Peck yes I'm always talking to him about
it because like I feel like it's so and
I think he's one of the few who've come
out on the other end like extremely
healthy and balanced and like been
through therapy and he obviously went
through a dark time but like he came out
on the other end I have so many
questions for him all the time I wasn't
expecting you to have this take about
this at all about what about this like
this kind of respect everyone's battles
but it kind of feels
like is this just in the news today was
it like a really yeah she was on the
podcast literally two days ago what
whose podcast pen Badgley pin Badgley
has a podcast pod crushed it's called
podc crushed it's on serm Sor I even
heard that and I it didn't even yeah no
he's always posting about it on Tik Tok
so I am familiar with the podcast and he
had teased that Jenny Humphrey his
fictional little
every was like and this is the headline
that came out of it which I'm shocked by
I thought it would be something Gossip
Girl related wow wow it felt like a
reach of like this is my battle that I'm
fighting but now I okay no she said that
alienating feeling really carried
through cuz then she got cast on Gossip
Girl when she was 12 which is so young I
didn't even realize that at the time and
all the other uh her her castmates were
much older than her so she wasn't like
hanging out with them and like being
friends she was much younger and she was
alone a lot and she ended up leaving the
show after four years so it was kind of
like like that initial alienation
feeling that she got from The Grinch
That kind of carried her through her
whole experience oh I know that sucks
you wouldn't you you you wouldn't see a
child working at Burger King so why are
they on set for 12 hours a day I know I
used to when I was like growing up I
grew up in like the Hannah Montana Drake
and J it was my dream like I all I
wanted was to have my own wizards of wly
play something like that and now as an
adult like Beyond grateful that that
wasn't me not that it was ever even an
option but did you did you ever hear
those commercials on listen on the radio
does your child watch Han Montana do you
want to be on a show with like the Sweet
Life of Zack and Cody where we have open
auditions casting uh I went to one you
did yeah I wanted I wanted to be on Zach
and Cody how old were you uh I had to be
12 okay that's old enough yeah um and I
you do a i a monologue yeah and I I was
I was I was probably younger because I
was I my piano teacher that my mom made
me take piano uh I piano I did guitar as
well wish I would have suuck with it all
the things I I was pissed at my mom
about I that is literally like the bane
of growing up imagine if I could just
like I still can't play guitar I cannot
play piano I'm like I don't want to go
to tennis every day I would have killed
to be good at
tennis I would have I know stick with it
um stick with it kids yeah the message
to the the 8-year-old listeners just
stick with it go go to piano today um
you were saying you went to the audition
I went to the audition it was in
Brownsville Texas which is are you from
Texas yes
yeah um like almost next to Mexico like
like very small town yeah very
very uh very far south and it was at a
mall oh no it was at a hotel in like a
banquet room totally empty classic we
went and did our auditions and they gave
you like a little card in a deck if you
made the next one they say you have been
you have been chosen why you made the
next round I made the next round and you
know what the next round was singing
move forward with giving us
$3,000 so that we can take you to the
actual audition in front of oh it's an
MLM uh or like sex trafficking honestly
I don't know wait that's crazy so you
obviously did not go it was dark well
yeah my parents were like no obviously
not that's crazy you can go back to
tennis and hopefully get a college
scholarship you know did you yeah I had
to you had a tennis College oh no no I
didn't get it I had to go back to tennis
practice the next day right right right
um wait that's a crazy story yeah no I
I'm wondering how many people if anybody
made it from those things no who if
speak sound off in the comments did you
ever pay the $3,000 and what happened
next I think it was like maybe even more
than $3,000 it's like it's like a big
chunk and it makes me like pretty sex it
wasn't even a guaranteed taking
advantage of of people and kids yeah
well my only similar story to that is
when I was in the eighth grade I did um
I entered into this it was it wasn't
like an essay competition it was like
this history competition you could
either write an essay you could do a
performance a history competition yeah
yeah um I don't really even remember
what the prize was but I I just decided
to do a performance of the great a onew
woman show of the great Hana senes I
don't know if anybody knows her she was
a paratrooper in World War II one of the
very few females um Jewish queen and I
did like a kind of really stunning um
onew woman show and I did end up placing
uh I believe I got first place and it's
important to know no way yeah in the
state but it's important to know that
there were only three kids who went for
their performance route um tons of kids
did like an essay or an oral
presentation but I just of course had to
be like
and I'm like on the floor and I remember
like my dad was really late to driving
me and I got there so late and I got
there like late out of breath it was
also like in this like Conference Center
decrepit abandoned building yeah and I
just like I just I just killed it
honestly and it was really beautiful I
was in the eth grade so how old are you
in the eth
grade 13 14 1 14 yeah I was old enough
to know better you know no better I got
like a a plaque like it was I mean it
was humiliating I don't know what I was
doing I I'm I'm I'm caught up on the on
the history competition I don't remember
like what the the the the competition
was you know there's like you know essay
writing competitions there was like a
historical something presentation I
don't know my obviously my eighth grade
teacher Mrs Casten she saw something in
me and she helped me obviously put
together the performance um and she was
right cuz I won that's that's huge
almost by default that sticks with you
cuz you're like still on fire about it
proud yeah I would like to get to the
bottom of the history competition piece
but I'm going to have to look further
into my documentation and find out what
exactly it was they always I remember
like every year there was something with
like the teachers like if you can sent
we're going to send your essay off do
whatever it was something like that okay
I can't recall exactly what it was all
right well Taylor momson thanks for
sharing your tra on a podcast today's
episode is brought to you by Mattress
Firm do you sleep better when you're at
a hotel is your mattress more than 5 to
8 years old can you see your mattress
sagging if so you may be overdue to find
a new mattress and Mattress Firm is here
to help finding a new mattress is like
probably one of the most exciting
Journeys to go on and Mattress FM makes
it so easy and it's really like like
mattresses can be life-changing
especially if it's for Mattress Firm it
can be intimidating knowing what type of
mattress that you need just to get a
quality night sleep but mattress firms
Sleep Experts get over 200 hours of
training so they can paare you with the
right mattress and accessories to get a
quality night's sleep the right mattress
can help alleviate pain tossing and
turning and even regulate your
temperature to help you sleep cooler
which is a game changer especially in
the summer this New York Heatwave
demonic and I've got the right mattress
my mattress is for Mattress her yeah
that's right um You can take their
online mattress matcher quiz you'll be
matched with a high quality mattress at
every P Price Point from top brands like
temper Pedic Sterns and Foster Serta
purple Beauty Rest sleepies and more my
mattress is from Mattress Firm it is
temper Pedic I love it it's perfect for
me and Ben but you know mattresses are
personal so you know go to Mattress Firm
meet with a sleep Expert Plus their low
price guarantee you can be confident
that you'll find the perfect mattress at
the best price so big deals on better
sleep are here early shop the black fry
Friday sale now in store or online at
mattressfirm.com love that they're
getting ahead of it the black the Black
Friday now sale is going on in store and
online at mattressfirm.com don't miss
out because having the right mattress
can really set you up for having the
right life you know you don't want to be
cranky you don't want to be Miz and it
could be your mattress so
mattressfirm.com or shop in store
today's episode is also brought to you
by better help sometimes we're faced
with the crossroads in life and we don't
know which path to take maybe you're
thinking about a career change or
feeling like your relationship needs
some TLC whatever it is therapy can help
you map out your future and trust
yourself to find the way forward so this
might be your sign maybe you've been
thinking about it for some time maybe
you've kind of reached the end of what
you can handle on your own and it is
okay to ask for help and you know a
therapist can be an amazing way to do
that and better help is an amazing
really accessible platform to get
started with therapy whether you're a
therapy veteran and you're looking for
someone new or you've never tried
therapy so if you're thinking of
starting better of starting therapy give
better help a try it's done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule SCH
just fill out a brief questionnaire and
get match with a licensed therapist and
one of the best parts I think is that
you can switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge a huge part of therapy
is just finding the right match and you
might be matched with a therapist who's
a lovely person but just not the right
match for you better help like gets rid
of all like the awkwardness and you can
just switch it up they won't charge you
it's fabulous and whatever you're
comfortable with you can talk on um text
you can video chat you can phone call
whatever Medium you're most comfortable
with better help will will get to work
for you so let therapy be your map with
better help visit better help.com toast
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com toast betterhelp.com
thank you betterhelp for sponsoring
today's episode our next story um I'm
sure everybody has seen those photos of
Kanye West in a very compromising
position with his like girlfriendwife in
Venice um the Venetian water taxi
company that he had used has now banned
him for NSFW Behavior so uh the boat
company has banned kany and his partner
Bianca Sor after images surfaced last
week of the two in a compromising
position in the back of a water taxi in
a statement to the independent a
spokesperson for Vena Turismo mfi the
water taxi company based in the Italian
city said that West and sorri quote will
certainly no longer be welcome aboard
our company's boats we completely
disassociate ourselves from such acts
and behaviors Kanye and his girly were
photographed last week in what appeared
to be a sex act on the back of the boat
with sensory kneeling in of West and
West's naked tushy in some of the photos
we got we got tushy we got tush it was
crazy I didn't never in my life did I
think I would see Kanye West butt cheek
no it was I think it was just one butt
cheek too it was it was honestly when I
first saw the photos I didn't even
assume that it was a [__] because it
was such a bizarre she was just kind of
like appeared to be sitting in front of
him and I thought maybe his pants were
just like low that's the style sometimes
fashion I didn't honestly my first
thought wasn't erotic no I didn't know
until just now that people thought it
was a [__] oh it was though like
confirmed really yeah why no that's not
okay no it's literally not okay in
public when you're a public figure none
of it is okay and I stand with vazia
taxi
company I stand with fania I just want
to make sure the right the name of the I
I stand first and
foremost with Venia turiso Mo we stand
with you we do that's not cool it's not
a good look um
I can't get over the first picture I saw
of kany butt crack and it wasn't even
like a little bit of butt crack his P
his pants are cheek that's pretty it's
Kanye it's bold to do that take your
pants off he put it out there so now we
have no choice but to like talk about it
what did you think of the tush I thought
it was pretty nice it was a fat ass yeah
like it was you know when I was in high
school me and all my friends used to
call somebody who had like a big juicy
ass but used to call it an unexpected
cuz it's just like unexpected that you'd
be walking around high school with a big
juicy ass you know he had his big old
ass out on the Venia Mori Mii Mill yeah
he had an unexpected like oh an
unexpected I love that yeah it was cuz
it was it was unexpected um can I see
the pictures that in that article of
course I would love to just get my eyes
on the visual assuming that they're
putting the oh no not them not putting
the photos I'll get the photo for you
it's really oh not my iPad being on full
volume like a grandmother Kanye West by
the way when you go to search his name
it's quite literally the first thing oh
here you go cool full ass he loves that
Legacy that's crazy that's humiliating
that's really not okay that's not okay
behavior mama mia Mama M Mia what I'm
sure vetsa was was think that's what the
Italians are saying my people were
saying zav zav it's not respectful it's
not
nice it's hard for me to form thoughts
about this genuinely like this is the
one story that you guys sent over and I
was like oh I'll that I don't even need
to study up you a hot take here I
don't let me think I love a hot take so
okay I can make one okay you know when
you're on a boat mhm and you're like
this is international waters 100% Like
Anything could happen it's true like you
kind of get swept away in the beauty and
just like the the timelessness
yeah I have a code on no one's going to
see my big juicy ass right but how do
you think being a public figure factors
into that line of thinking uh it's it's
it's I would say careless but it's not
careless it's it feels intentional it
feels intentional but what is the
intention I'm so confused what is the
intention I don't know I also always
forget that he's with this girl cuz he
had like a string of girlfriends and now
him and this girl got like fake legally
married so I totally forgot that he even
had a girl with him fake legally married
like like they call each other husband
and wife but it's like not legal they're
not married but they had like a ceremony
every picture I see of
her feels
like feels like she's lost like she's
like how did I you know how am I here
what do you think her friends and family
like think of her cuz she kind of R Rose
to stard them almost overnight very you
know Allah Julia Fox I don't I don't
know I don't know I don't I bet she has
not chatted with them in a while yeah
cuz I feel like if if she had any close
friends or family they'd be reaching out
saying what's going on let's get you out
of here she's kind of in her untethered
era yeah and no one really talks about
her that much like I every every time
she's with him but anytime she's I don't
know anything about this woman no I know
I feel like Julia fox really got like
the best opportunity as Kanye's
girlfriend there was a lot of intrigue
and then long after they broke up she
still kind of a darling of New York
she's a media darling she's at Fashion
Week front row and the string of
girlfriends after Kanye did not get the
same sort of treatment yeah um
beginner's luck I guess chalk it up
beginner's luck I can't believe have you
had Julia Fox on this podcast I have not
I feel like you would you guys would
Jive I honestly can think of two people
more different which makes convers you
could talk back and forth can I ask you
a totally unrelated question yeah are
you wearing a Baby G
watch no it's a
okay you want to hold it sure it looks
like a Baby G from back in the day I
forgot I I was supposed to put on my
nice watch to be on explain to me ivora
um it's it's it's a smaller company and
and they reached out and they were like
do do you like our watches I'm like I
get I get an ad on Instagram for your
watches every single day actually so I
do love them this is great promo for
them I literally thought it was a baby G
I'm like I'm like you're so Baby G I'm
so Baby G when are baby G's making a
comeback I think right now after this
airs because honestly no offense to or
I'm sure you've got a great brand but
this is a Baby G yeah well I don't know
if Baby G is still with us today I think
that they are and I just want to say
there's something incredibly underrated
about a digital like I cannot tell time
I mean I can but I would take me this
long to find out it's 8:21 you ask me
what time it is uh do you have the time
by the way oh sure let me grab my watch
it's um that's 8:22 that's how long it
would take me on like an analog analog
yeah I cannot read those and then I
panic and then you throw some Roman
numer oh I'm done Roman numeral it's
never that's why I can't watch football
I I look oh no the Super Bowl LBI like
what you don't need to what is
lvi uh Louis Vuitton International I
don't know I I don't know I can't do
those I I stare at the analog clock
until someone's like I'm like oh it's ah
and then someone else will say it but
what's so crazy is I used to really [__]
heavily with analog clocks um in high
school and middle school just so I could
know how much [__] time left was in
this class
that was like kind of my PE knowing how
to tell time era I just knew where the
hand would be that's true too I love
that how did we get to clocks from Kano
s big juicy ass that's a good question
let's backtrack yeah I asked you about
your watch because you were talking
about his Big Ben yeah honestly it's a
fruitless Endeavor to try and oh that
that was a that was a question out of
left field about the watch that threw a
wrench in the whole tangent it was and
I'm sorry I keep touching the mic it's
you're okay it's connected to your mic
as well no it's not and so I'll touch it
and then years will start moving I'm
like are we having an earthquake but you
guys don't have earthquakes no we don't
but you do we do never felt couldn't be
me I know well our next story is an
opportunity for us to finally talk about
ourselves which is so exciting because
we have some US Open news because one of
the players like really was deeply on
well yesterday during to day his name is
denil meddev he did win but he warned
the UMP he said someone's going to die
in this intense heat after he won
yesterday so soaked with sweat as the
temperature neared 95° on the hottest
day at this year's US Open the champion
from 2021 walked slowly the towel off
between points of his victory and he
looked into a Courtside camera and
issued what sounded like a mix between a
warning and a play he said you cannot
imagine one player is going to die and
they're going to see the only thing that
is a little bit let's call it dangerous
is that the question is how far could we
go English is not his first language
just please keep that in mind I'm not
sure what we can do because probably we
cannot stop the tournament for 4 days
because it's been what 3 4 days it's
been brutal like this because then it
basically ruins everything for the TV
even the tickets everything it ruins
everything so I don't think that this
could be done but he was just basically
begging the powers that be at the US
Open to do something about the heat I
can't even imagine being there yesterday
during the day cuz we got there no 7:30
caring Madison Keys it was brutal and
it's by the way it's important to note
yesterday when we were at the uh at
night when I left I checked it was 87°
yeah Outside Inside the stadium the it's
an open air stadium so it's like half
open
half closed like it's it's got like a
big hole in the top right it's perfectly
said it's got a big hole in the top it
is at least 10 degrees hotter inside the
stadium than it is outside you noticed
that too of course when I went outside
I'm like wait if I was sitting outside
in this I could handle it it's it's I
think it's because there's a wind tunnel
situation happening outside so there's a
breeze inside the stadium it's it's just
stagnant hot air it's crazy fog thick
it's crazy and you're sitting there next
to Ben yeah I was sitting there next to
my My Buddy Hunter who's you know like
this and unbearable I was like I'm kind
of having like maybe a panic attack no I
was definitely getting like a little
nauseous we're going to get ripped to
shreds about being dramatic I can't tell
you no we're not being dramatic you let
me tell you the level of this I'm going
to the US Open I got to dress like I
like I continued playing tennis of
course and I wore tennis dress yeah I I
should have worn a tennis dress I wore
pants I found a Paras SC from someone
and I cut the legs off my pants and I
threw my underwear in the trash smart
didn't help oh yeah and I wore a sweater
like over because at that point I was
like now I'm in shorts I have to keep
the sweater over unbearable I'm
drenching sweat but at least the sweater
was covering the the the massive amounts
of sweat on my back the marks but
anytime someone touched me they'd say oh
don't touch did you that's Ru touch
don't touch it looked like I went
swimming it was hard it was really
honestly unbearable I brought a fan with
me which was the absolute like savior of
my life people getting these fans
everybody had a fan honestly I've had
one in my purse for the last like three
Summers it is the only way to survive
and when I got up off my seat like
literally I like had my thighs like left
marks it was like wet I was like sliding
on my seat I was soaked I can't it was
crazy and I do wonder that stadium that
roof closes it closes when it's like
snowing and raining right right I do
have to imagine the facility has air
conditioning and I don't know why when
they know it's going to be a 90° day in
the morning why they don't close it and
put on air conditioning well they closed
it a little bit during the day I read
that article to block people from the
Sun for the Sun but then the Sun the
Shadows were making it like harder for
the players to see the balls going in
and out of the shade and actually this
player in his interview said that
towards the end of the first set he
actually couldn't even see the ball
because he was just like dizzy and
nauseous and the other players like
heart was palpitating and apparently the
US Open is using crazy amounts of ice
fans and last night I saw the at the uh
at this when they were switching sets
Carlos Alcatraz alcatra alarz alarz sat
down and they put this like tube of ice
around just close the
roof ice are we close the roof ancient
Roman we just discovered fire we
discovered ice put the AC on no it's
moronic put the AC on put the AC on it
was it really was unenjoyable
and honestly I have been loving watching
the US Open from home and I can't think
of a better way to watch than from the
comfort of my own bed and air
conditioning well the weather's going to
be so nice I think starting tomorrow
which is just ass I know because we
really went like during the peak it's
just Kanye West big juicy ass it's Kanye
big juicy ass I think in time the US
Open ends on Sunday I think in time for
the finals like it will be okay well
last year at this time I was here as
well and it was nice as it was so nice
that's why they do it in September it's
supposed to be nice um I just I I feel
for the I can't imagine being a player I
can't I imagine how I felt last night
getting home I sat for a few hours like
imagine standing running and jumping and
hitting for four hours can't I do think
that I was sweating more than them
sitting completely still I was trying
not to move mhm and I was like there's
no way they're sweating more than me
there's no way they have towels I they
have towels down there I desperately
needed a towel for my seat I was housing
I had paper towel kind of like scrunched
up all over my neck and body CU I was
and I was just like I I I don't care I
lost like the I want to like look good
for the US I lost that like almost
immediately when I sat down course the
second I was like I I put my hair up I'm
like I don't care here's here's
something that I would like to chat
about
okay the most incredible thing I've ever
noticed in my life
most unimaginable phenomenon is how
really like Attractive people don't seem
to sweat at all and they are wearing
pants and jackets and they're hot and
then they don't sweat I've seen the
Northern Lights less amazing than seeing
a hot person that doesn't sweat I agree
there's definitely two types of people
in the universe and it's people who are
deeply affected by temperature
regulation and people who are like
always cold you know yeah and the people
who are always cold and whose body
temperature is like always lower when
it's really hot they're a little
uncomfortable but they're not wiping off
their makeup and putting their hair in a
bun and like sweating through their
clothes makeup would come off makeup is
a really and I was like really concerned
I'm like I'm not going to the US Open
without makeup on but it was a major
concern yeah oh wow yeah you got to go
waterproof you have to go water I've
always said that you've always said that
I was yeah I was uh pretty miserable and
we saw alcarez last night and I was like
I really want to stay for the rest of
this match and I had to be the guy that
was like excuse me I'm actually going
they're like you're really leaving right
now I know it like it was it was
unfathomable like for real it was just
like kind of I was just like very first
world problems how did you get home from
the US Open by the way we had driven and
it was actually so funny because parking
is like a mess but there's like all
these like random lots and there was
like a very right by the players's lot
there was like an empty lot and I was
like can we park here and the guy was
like zel me a hundred bucks yeah I'm
like you got it and it was literally the
easiest thing it was a Ponzi scheme like
the US open's kind of chaos uh as soon
as you leave those Gates right past the
polo Suite yep chaos it is it is no how
did you leave did you take an Uber so we
walk out we're we took the train there
because I was going to say the train
really is like the fastest way and when
we were in the car there was traffic I
was like this this is what you get when
you don't take the train I'm so
unprepared for just New York in general
but I was at the rowing Blazers event
and I went and I saw the line and now I
go I don't have time to wait in the line
then get on the train so I I'm scared of
the train kind of like missing it
messing up yeah no it's you have to be
prepared so I I just like didn't even go
I went all the way to the event and then
I didn't even go in I looked at it I
took a picture and then I was I have to
go to the US openen and cut my legs off
my pants and so I like got there
whatever we went to leave and we turn
around we're like let's get an Uber
thinking we have beat the system no the
Uber off is so far the entire state of
New York was trying to get an Uber yeah
of course and so we walk and we we're
like let's leave to to the the
expressway we'll go under the bridge and
then we'll call an Uber over there um so
you're out of the zone as you walk out
people are like uh you can get in my car
you can get in my I'm like ready right
now call them in New York they're called
Gypsy cabs they're like unlicensed car
services for the most part they're safe
by the way they only take cash that's
the annoying thing I would have made it
work I was like I'm walking through and
and the first one is like we can take
you home I go I don't want to get
murdered I'm going to go get in my Uber
second one we take you
up I mean I could get murdered like I'm
like I'm sweating so bad they are
they're pretty safe I finally we found
this dude and he was like shorter than
me I'm like I could maybe fight him off
yeah if he tried to kill me and at least
we'd be a we' just be out of this we
call new Uber yeah it's kind of crazy to
like get into an unmarked vehicle but in
New York there is like a subculture
they're pretty safe it's just people try
to make a living for the most part it's
not people trying to murder you know
yeah you got to read The Vibes too you
definitely got to read The Vibes that's
so fair I didn't love seeing like girls
alone leaving with the arm mared
Vehicles if I was with like my sisters I
wouldn't do it but if I was with Ben I
would yeah yeah I was I was just talking
to B actually about how Miser my husband
you were talking to my husband yeah I
was talking to your husband on the way
here I didn't know you guys talk we talk
all the time no way I love that on
Instagram and the DMS he was like I that
was the most miserable I've ever Ben
talking about the was so Ben was like
really I looked at him at one point and
he's I'm like very easily inconvenience
like if I'm if I feel one drop of sweat
the world is ended he has a higher bar
for putting up with [__] I looked at him
his
face his face was like purple and I was
like are you okay and he was like
honestly no like he he was like
suffering in silence and I was like we
can leave like he was really he looked
like he had just I don't even know what
he looked like he was deeply unwell and
I was like oh my god I've never seen you
like this I'm like his face was like
kind kind of looked like swollen was he
trying to like power through he was just
like being quiet he's like CLA he hasn't
complained yet I need to like be the
strong and Ben's really not into tennis
I'm the one who's like more into it so I
did like it was like my thing that he
came to um it wasn't like I was putting
up with sports for him like I do when I
go to the Nick game um so he was just
like suffering in silence and he was
being a good husband I saw him I was
like oh we can go it was crazy I can
even imagine that's like it was horrible
I don't even I there's no words you can
really say I hate to be like a an an
ungrateful snob because tennis is like
so snobby but it really it it it was a
great match but like it was really
unbearable at some points today's
episode is also brought to you by Babel
this summer you can start speaking a new
language with Babel why because it works
so instead of paying hundreds of dollars
for a private tutor or fooling yourself
with language apps that are little more
than games Babel's quick 10-minute
lessons are designed by over 150
language experts to help you start
speaking a new language in as little as
3 weeks so it's literally never a bad
time to learn a new language there's a
million reasons why you might want to
you're taking a trip you want to expand
your horizons you know whatever your
reason is Babble is the best way to do
it you know I'm kind of I'm kind of like
not fluent but like I'm really kind of
killing it with Babel in Spanish so let
me ask you a question le le esta
gustando podcast are you luy listening
to my podcast I think you are and I
wouldn't have been able to do that
without Babble so Babel's designed for
real people for real conversations all
of Babel's tips and tools uh for
learning a new language are approachable
accessible rooted in real life
situations and there delivered with
conversation-based teaching with over 10
million subscriptions sold Babel is real
language learning for real conversations
if you're taking a trip I cannot
recommend Babble enough it's just such a
great thing to have like a baseline
knowledge of the language it's safer
it's more effect effective way of
traveling so here's a special limited
time deal for our listeners to get you
started right now get 55% off your
Babble subscription only for our
listeners at babble.com toast that's
babbel.com
toast get 55% off at babble / toast
again that's spelled
babbel.com toast rules and restrictions
May apply yeah I I don't really
understand it's been it's been miserable
everything that we've done here but that
was like crazy and it was more miserable
because I'm looking around and no one
seemed to be in the same state I was I
know because it really was like seeing a
once in a-lifetime player like he's
really Carlos he's a number he's we
stayed for him I stayed for him and I
stayed as long as I could for him yeah
we we did what we could and I took a
bunch of videos so I could rewatch of
course of course as long as I want the
whole next set I feel like I've just
kind of delayed the fifth and final
story cuz I like genuinely don't want to
talk about this Delta Airlines flight
yeah um but I guess we have to so we
haven't spoken about it yet so if you
don't know what I'm talking about there
was like a biohazardous event on a Delta
flight that caused the flight to turn
around um people on the flight were
saying they were smelling one of the
worst things they've ever smelled it was
unclear like what really had happened we
now have gotten more information we've
got footage from the inside of the
flight one of the passengers was filming
as he
deed so here's the headline I I just
want to say these are the New York
post's words not my words okay
passengers aboard diarrhea
plane have shared their ordeal quote it
was dribbled down the aisle smelled
horrible grow style passengers have
detailed the ordeal of being stuck on a
Delta flight that was forced to turn
back after someone could not contain
their explosive diarrhea which left the
crew ripping out carpet to contain The
Biohazard quote it was an experience
that I hope no one has to go through
Maria Beal's Basinger told the Daily
Mail just 2 hours into its 8h hour trik
to Barcelona the flight was diverted
back to Atlanta here's what a fellow
passenger had to say I hope that poor
woman just that had this experience
recovers it was dribbled down the aisle
it smelled horrible it was pretty bad
the vanilla scented disinfect
disinfectant used on it only made it
smelled like vanilla [__] that might be
the worst part for me worst part the
disinfectant is I know there the only
thing worse than [__] is a is a fruity
scent trying to cover up the [__] here's
what more people had to say the flight
was met by emergency vehicles and EMTs
carrying the sick passenger off the
plane after the plane landed it was
thoroughly clean they didn't leave
around 2:30 a.m. the pilots made the
right decision to turn around
considering the circumstances the ground
crew did a great job along with the
attendants and Pilots there's so much to
unpack from this entire ordeal but I
have to say you know who's coming out on
the other end Delta because everybody is
like really pleased with how they
handled the situation and like customer
service afterwards I'm sure everybody
got vouchers and refunds and all that
stuff so you know you would think this
would be a nightmare PR moment for Delta
but they're kind of coming out clean you
love Delta too right love yeah they're
they're becoming my favorite Airline
this helped a lot I actually been having
don't tell anyone like a United
moment yeah let me tell you because one
of my things is like I'm always going to
find the best like most this is because
something I learned from being friends
with the Points Guy The Points Guy y you
know you're taking a flight from New
York to LA yeah you could take any
Airline there's so many great ones Jeet
Blue Delta United but if you're like if
you do research on the type of plane
you're getting from different airlines
like you can find yourself on like the
newest plane with the best Wi-Fi that's
free and new seats like you know
sometimes you get on a plane you're like
damn this is an old plane yeah it's cuz
you didn't do your research what do how
do you know if it's a newer plane do
they so it all the planes have like the
Carfax yeah like they have um like
Boeing they have names yeah so you'll
Google the name and you go to like a
website like seat Guru and they'll tell
you about the
plane what yeah it's it's a lot more
work but it's worth it wow you're
putting in the man hours yeah cuz I'm
flights are [__] expensive like even
a slow like a short ass flight to
Florida these days is like 600 bucks so
if I'm spending it like I want the best
of the best I want the newest plane with
the fastest Wi-Fi and I want TVs you
know they're been doing that sometimes
you don't get a TV on a three-hour
flight you're nuts that is that should
be a lawsuit actually I don't know I
don't know when like boredom like
attention span became means for a
lawsuit but I think I would I would
definitely I would explode i' I'd be
feeling litigious I would have
biohazardous diarrhea if I didn't have a
a screen on a plan that's what happened
here um I think it's really interesting
the story is interesting I mean that I'm
I'm storing that I Fly for Free a lot
because my dad was a pilot so no wait
tell me all about that so I heard that
like when you're related to like a pilot
or or something like that you just pay
the taxes and fees yeah so what does
that usually cost for like an LA to New
York Flight 40 bucks wow can you get
first class uh if you get upgraded yeah
I mean there's open seats are you high
on a list because you're like friends
and family he's retired now so I'm I
moved way down but for a long time like
in college it was fun cuz I could just
like on the weekends like go see a
friend at a different college or
something and is there a limit on how
many prier no and what airl was your dad
a pilot for he was do what what airline
oh United so does that only apply to
United he gets a discount on like other
airlines as well I mean it's the that's
the best perks that I can imagine out of
like any job duh that's like accessible
and pilot is like such a prestigious job
like people have such respect for Pilots
I like it was so funny anytime I saw him
in the airport people would like shake
his hand and I'm like yeah he's not like
in the milit war you know like was he in
the military yeah he was and that's how
he got into uh flying yeah he was in the
yeah he flew planes wow that's so
fascinating it is it is cool so were you
there for like cuz I've been on planes
before where it's like a retiring Pilots
Last Flight and they do like that water
thing with like the hoses was there a
moment like that and were you there he
um there was something going on with so
he was at Continental and they merged
into United wow back Continental they
kept the logo which I like and they put
United on they should have ch they kept
should have kept Continental that's like
such a great Airline name yeah um but he
they had United was trying to save money
so they laid off like a bunch of Pilots
gave some Pilots the opportunity to
retire early got it and so he did that
so he actually didn't have like a final
flight which is kind of nice cuz it's so
sad it's kind of like Irish exit Vibes I
don't think I would want to be on it
would be sad but also be like kind of
awkward yeah okay so I will say like I
have been on a flight where it's a
retiring Pilot's last flight and his
like wife and kids come and it's like
very sweet but he always gets like
choked up and it's so sad like you know
just kind of being sended off into
retirement and there's an element of you
know of sadness to it so I agree and
definitely an element of awkwardness
because it's like it is like it's I was
excited to be a part of it but at the
same time like I'm traveling I'd like to
get off this plane can we hustle can we
move along yeah I don't and I don't know
this I don't know I don't know you
congrats true it's true yeah it's like I
accidentally got seated at the Habachi
table with someone whose birthday it is
like I do I sing Happy Birthday what
does have to do with me I would kind of
like the onion so let me ask you another
question so he is retired but you still
get the perks yeah a little bit it's
like I said it's like way way less
prioritized now M but like just now on
the way here he's like what flight do
you want to leave on tomorrow which is
nice and a lot of times from New York to
LA for some reason like it's wide open
yeah cuz there's so many airlines and so
many it's like a very popular route so I
can get a row wow which sometimes you
want the row over the the nicer seat
that requins yeah it's true a three seat
road to yourself is kind of extremely
luxurious yes it is and that's what you
have on the way here um no I had middle
seat in the very back because a family
with a toddler was in my seat and I go
that's my seat and they go oh they said
there was no one in this seat cuz like I
get on last if there's an open seat and
I was like oh no there is now cuz I'm
standing here and that's it uh so the
toddler you were in between the toddler
and the parents I was on the aisle so I
was like excited to pee nine times on my
flight and uh and didn't have explosive
diarrhea the flight attendent walks up
and says yeah flight attendant comes up
and says there's actually a seat open in
the very back middle next to those two
giant men and I go and she goes she goes
if you don't want to separate the family
of
course you [__] by the way I just want
to say that's so crazy had you been a
paying customer right you have every
right to say no like it's really not
your problem I would not have yeah but
you know you're kind of a grifter so so
you took the seat I took the seat in the
back I took the seat in the back crazy
yeah it was almost US Open level hot
back there next to the two men and the
bathroom uh in the bathroom yeah which
that sucked as well yeah but that fell
second to at Le you kept the family
together I did I'm a hero yeah know that
that kind of karma will come back like
you will get upgraded to First Class
like when you least expect it in the
coming months I really believe that yeah
I'm putting that knockwood I have I have
to ask did you shift conversation
because of the poop I did sh well I
shifted conversation because honestly
like I don't want to talk about this
Delta flight but I really was and and am
fascinated by people who are related to
Pilots I really I think it's so
interesting so like what was your dad's
schedule you know like when you were
growing up yeah he I mean he like missed
Christmas a lot and like stuff like that
yeah so like we ended up not being like
a serious like birthday family because
you know so unpredictable yeah so it's
it's it's been then like towards the end
of my like living with my parents he
would work like six days a month wow oh
that's nice CU he did International only
so he did like London Paris Tokyo and
was it ever a like a thought that maybe
you wanted to be a pilot like your dad
my little sister's a pilot now no way
yeah and she's flying I don't think I
can she's flying some big name to like
music festivals is she flying private
yes she's flying private wow is she like
a a full Captain co- Captain how old is
she don't know she's 24 wow she's young
I've been in a plane with her before and
and she's going Delta Niner ner right
I'm like I don't are you being serious
are you like messing with me I actually
was in a I probably shouldn't say that I
don't know the aviation roles but she
was like
don't nothing illegal nothing illegal
she just that's so cute that she like
followed in your dad's your dad likes
her better I think in many ways yes yeah
um I don't think that there's many ways
that they would like me better I could
see them liking her better yeah she's
just got like got it going on I'm I
think it's really awesome that she's
doing that because I now have another
immediate family member that can that's
working if she goes commercial again
that's fabulous um yeah it's really cool
I love that well I have to say you
really blew it out of the water you did
you did a great job for actually wow
funny smart great anecdote honestly I'd
invite you back you would I would okay
well if you've enjoyed what you've heard
here today you have your own podcast
it's called Brook and Conor make a
podcast you drop episodes weekly weekly
yep anywhere you get your podcasts
follow the fibs on Tik Tok on Instagram
it's at fibula FIB that's the one thank
you for being here for real thank you
for having me enjoy the rest of your
time in New York thank you and thank you
guys so much for listening to the Dress
londay Morning Show where we deliv the
fast stories you need to know every Mond
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcast where
podcast can be found Spotify public
radio rast box all the places listen
podcast find us the tow about a
beautiful stuning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
our last episode of the week is tomorrow
and the great Ben Sofer celebrity will
be joining us in studio as my co-host so
you're not going to want to miss it love
you bye see
you